I am so ready for a vacation in Hawara's new waffle fabric.
It is extra flowy and really cool to the touch.
I'm like, I just need that breeze blowing, flowing.
I love it. It's just.
It's everything Halar is known for,
the amazing waffle fabric.
It's flowy, it's stretchy,
and it's at the.
The V neck cut
and the little short sleeves
really gives you that smaller appearance up top.
And then the waistband and then the wide, flowy legs.
This is, like, so flattering on your body.
I especially love if it.
If you're going somewhere formal,
it really does look like it can be a gown
depending on how you're standing.
I just. I love it.
It just feels so elegant and effortless at the same time.
And there's pockets.
Big, deep pockets.
I am 5 9, 165 pounds.
I usually do wear like a large.
I size down and got a medium because it is so flowy.
I like it to fit a little more snug.
Any size you get,
it's gonna be amazing.
And you don't even have to worry about the size
because it's free shipping,
free returns,
and there's a huge discount for first time buyers at the TikTok shop.
It's linked right here.